- But you're so good at
finding words for the things
that we feel, but can't vocalize.
So what are some things
that you're feeling in 2021?
- Well, I think I'm feeling in my job
for the last decade and a half
has been to listen to women. Right.
So I listened to how they're feeling and
I've noticed something really interesting,
which is that we're all struggling. Right.
- Yeah
But we're all struggling with
about the same 20 things.
And we all think that
there's something wrong
with us personally.
- Yeah. So we're like,
- Yeah, we think we special.
- Yeah, or like, there's
something wrong with us, you know
like why can't I get
everything done at home and
get everything thing done
at work? Or, you know,
how do I carry this whole
emotional load of family
without the partner like all these things
and what I think that, you
know, we can do hard things
and all of my work and
feminism I guess, is about,
it's just reminding women
there's nothing wrong with you,
there's something wrong with
these systems and institutions
that are demanding everything of us,
but not supporting us in any ways. Right?
We're not, women are not screwed up,
We're just often screwed over. Right? And
- I'm gonna make that necklace now
- Yeah, right.
like sometimes we don't need more therapy,
We need reproductive freedom
and we need equal pay and
we need to feel safe walking
down our own streets.
So I think when we get together
and talk about these things,
we start to remember that
there's nothing wrong with us and
that when we're not like
silenced and siloed,
we can just quit blaming
ourselves and each other
and we can start going out and
changing the world to fit us
instead of the other way around.
- Tower in numbers as well.
- Yeah.
- Yes agreed, agreed, I love you.
Okay. I'm very, I've been
very excited about this .
Glennon's talked about
the idea of quitting,
which good God I'm sudden so
you're not allowed to quit.
So like anything, but
that's sometimes it's,
it's necessary for
survival though that you,
you say that, right.
- I love quitting, I would
never start anything hard.
That's the secret of we can do hard things
is that you have to quit
them every single day.
I mean, quitting used to be
this beautiful idea when the,
the, the, the word quitting
came from the word quietus,
which literally means to
set yourself free, right.
It only got a negative connotation
around the industrial revolution
when people became machines
to squeeze everything out of, right.
- Just suck the life off us.
- Just suck the life off
- Yes
- Right. So we have to make
quitting, seem like for wimps
- Yeah
- So that we can continue to
suck everything out of people,
which is why, you know,
these amazing women now,
Simone Biles, Naomi Osaka.
- Yeah
- Who are saying, no,
actually my humanity is
more important than your
experience of me. Right?
- Wow. Yeah, I had to say that
actually, personally, yeah
- Absolutely
- No I was doing too many things,
there were too many places
and it was one of those
things where it's like,
I felt like too, you, you
can't really Excel at anything
if you're doing everything,
you know what I'm saying?
You can't Excel at any
like personal at anywhere
if you know, doing everything
so I think that's true.
- Yeah. And isn't it a beautiful
thing for a woman to say,
I will not abandon myself. I will abandon
you're the world's expectations of me
before I will abandon
myself and then the world
loses it because the world hates a woman
who chooses herself over the
world's experience of her,
especially when it's a
woman of color. Right?
- Don't watch this show,
don't watch the show.
That's what I'm saying.
If you don't want that.
- It's a revolution quit everything
- Yes
- Quit